[Music]
first question who of you were was
already attending my talk in the morning
on the other
side okay three so please be in mind uh
there's tiny repetition to get everyone
on board you only three I think it's
still worth it uh try to focus then um
most part of of the thing which is um
yeah in addition to the
notebook oh yeah thanks for um aut to
going to the next slide so
um yeah that's me do it worked it was
already
automatically so um yeah let me tell you
a bit more um individual things so jool
and iio is actually my person as of now
still so I I really am kind of a uh a
single entrepreneur tried a couple of
co-founders here and there didn't work
out so far try to think about other ways
but so far um it's still kind of a good
way for me just to do it on my own and
try to Envision this goal of creating
value for for others and yeah but for
other companies to then finally make
something which hopefully can sustain
itself the beginning is always um a lot
of hassle to kind of get known and yeah
and build something uh really useful but
um so far super interesting Challenge
and yeah you learn a lot you need to do
a lot of different things which you
haven't thought before and yeah and I'm
super happy that I can be here today and
present to you kind of my current dream
um yeah what I what I like to give to
the world
and yeah so the focus as of now is
actually reactive notebook and because
of this I I want
to
um yeah give an overview about this
first which is a bit overlapping to the
talk and the morning I already gave and
the second part is then about the the
cloud deployment so that you can use
this already and yeah this is also
intended to be used by
companies um yeah more about that than
later so cloud. jen. this is the the
website where you can just go to and
then check it out you log in with GitHub
and yeah and then everything is there
yeah you get um automatically a free
access period of a couple of hours but
you can just reach out to me and I'll
extend your your test period for yeah up
to a month I usually say but if you if
you're really interested to test it more
uh we also find the
solution okay let's hook in it um
so uh so this is a bit surprising I was
hoping okay not works I was clicking too
often so I have a a little video
prepared as a live demo alternative so
this is kind of the the key part around
yeah everything is around this um some
of you saw this already morning so on
the right side we see the key aspect
which is a reactive notebook and um it's
like Jupiter you have this these cells
but it's also not like Jupiter and and
that these cells they automatically
update if you change
something all which depends on it will
be
rerun and the order is not decisive yeah
um you can do the order as you want um
so here we see the initial layout um
which has the output above the input we
can change this we can also have the
output below the input which is much
more intuitive for for a couple of and
also for me um but the default has it on
top and yeah so
we we just imported a square root from
math one example and that updated to to
grab the new dependencies and we we
built kind of Rich document yeah self
documenting output for example with
markdown but we also could use HTML so
there's a similar HTML grapper around it
so yeah that what in Jupiter would be
two different cell types here now is
just one of the same cell type um yeah
just a a markdown string or an HTML
string which then output and and rener
um with with Rich output so here we have
kind of a small latch example that you
see that it's the usual um mathematics
like um markdown which you have and and
the key thing is that it's re rendered
rich and the final part of this little
animation is that you will see that we
can also hide the input it m makes makes
a lot of sense for for these pure output
cells and this is now the final step and
yeah and yeah so this little example
actually computes
pi and
yeah so the core idea is now that we
have such an interface which um which as
of now looks more like like standard
Jupiter but we can now extend it with
with graphical inputs and self updates
these are the two things which I want to
present you in the next two slides so
that despite this looks so simple it's
out of a sudden like a full web page or
a full um data process so it's still um
yeah so last bits um now now we are
there it's still kind of really just a a
script light thinking yeah you just do
something and it's really like a script
actually it's even stored as a script so
what you see here is now stored as a
python file on on the disk and they are
all sorted in the correct order so that
you if you would execute the python file
it's really just doing what we have here
in the correct order so the dependencies
are
resolved and we use this later
on so let me go to the next slide um so
this is now the key part um so that that
you can get the feeling um this notebook
despite so simple really can can create
whatever you want so we have of course
some design defaults I would say yeah
you have the the font which we use here
yeah we can change this but but from
yeah from just using it it has a default
font but other than that yeah almost
everything is free so free to to be
changed we we can really put whatever we
want on on the top we can put a logo on
the right yeah so we can really adapt
this easily to whatever company Style We
would like while in Jupiter because you
have this um yeah more this the standard
experiment cell layout it's not so easy
to to just yeah change Jupiter into
something which is really fully
customized to your company there there
still this Jupiter layout in between so
we also have here kind of some cell
boundaries yeah but as you see if you
focus on the output part it's nothing
nothing left it's really just your
definition how you would like to make it
look and I I find this a really
important part so that we can um yeah
have this yeah to create really our
dashboards company dashboards and Etc
directly in this notebook so it's really
just just the same no extra step what I
built here is I imported from from a
Julia package actually because um The
Notebook is implemented in in
Julia um little help a package which
gives us interactive widgets so I I
already weree out here also and I told
it if someone is interested in in
building the IPython widgets no one
actually came to me I'm I'm very sad but
uh if someone is interested to help me
out the IPI widgets package would be
awesome to support and we have here now
a scrubbable which you've seen you can
drag and drop it and and change the
value which is our user input and we
have a a special function
bind which is now which now takes this
user input element this UI element and
updates a concrete variable with its
value and this kind of the key thing and
now we can change what we before have
been manually coding yeah n equals
something yeah or whatever input you
have yeah whatever choice you want to
make in your dashboard um you can now
just replace it by by some UI element
and it's a very natural flow you start
coding something experimentally and then
replace Parts by by interactivity it
helps you even in experiment mode to to
easily uh yeah check Alternatives but it
also is a step towards kind of a a
website dashboard I also sometimes call
it like a live
report and and we see here now we can
integrate it in other um markdown code
or HTML code and yeah and it updates
everything automatically so this is kind
of the key Spirit thanks to reactivity
we now transformed a notebook which
previously has been only experimental
ground yeah to do some some research to
try out some stuff and have something
which is which is sound yeah which is
valid which is
already yeah a product in a sense yeah
and
and this is yeah so let me rephrase so
what what is kind of the key ingredients
to get this we have a super flexible
layout yeah we have one type of cell
only and the output is whatever Rich
HTML you want and with this you can
really customize this to to whatever you
want there's no other prefixed
design and we have this reactivity which
makes that the code is always in a valid
State it's always re-executed it's
always
correct if you want or if it's not
correct you see it so it's more like a
script if you want if you like yeah and
scripts of course we also used to build
products yeah we run a script for
whatever and this is in a sense like a
fancy script yeah it has more
interactivity you can easily uh work
with it you have direct feedback as you
like it from Jupiter but still it has
this the semantics of a script and that
you you have it executed always
completely it's not like an intermediate
wrong state so and this is the second
big point that makes this possible to
deploy it as a product you you really
know that yeah if you develop it it's
like what I would like to deploy it's
not like in Jupiter you execute the one
the other cell and of course you are in
an uh bit chaotic environment in in
Jupiter and here you always know this is
this is like a state which I may deploy
which I may put into a
product okay so the last part of it is
um that there's the possibility of
making this grab updates from some
system and here's a very very tiny
example um which just re-executes it
again again and and CH the time so it
it's you can almost Overlook it but in
principle you can grab updates from
another service yeah uh you have maybe
an event system at your company and you
want to listen on events
um yeah or or just on a regular time so
that you regularly grab some updates
from some server and and this is super
important of course if you if you want
to deploy it you need to make it somehow
update to the current state so yeah it
needs to be up to date otherwise it's
not really useful oh yeah um this is a
little tiny thing I I se out today in
the morning we can switch the order from
input and output so now execut this
little helper output below which
switches it and we have it below which
is the mode I'm often using and this is
now kind of the key thing we can have
extra functionality which does some
something on the server side while this
is kind of we of course have this in our
browser it's like what we tell client
customer we can also do things on a on a
server side and here we just repeat it
um um every two seconds by by rounding
the next time yeah to to two seconds so
we repeat this very cell at in two
seconds and you see that it's updating
its own automatically I was not um yeah
it's probably not too long the videoos
holding then but this together makes
really for whatever you like yeah you
can transform
data uh just grab it from uh a topic
from a Kafka topic here and write it to
another topic you can um do just
processing you grab data at a fixed time
write it to somewhere else and you can
also do kind of just website interfaces
you you upload a PDF file and and pass
it in some way and you can insert data
into a database by using this dashboard
yeah is is the interface people can put
in data and this updates um your
database in the background yeah you can
do the others thing around you analyze
your data from database so it's really
super flexible you can do almost all
things which you usually yeah want to do
in in in data
applications oh yeah last part um you
have also the possibility to have Rich
output so that you have
real um it's not working that you
have uh plots and so I just wanted to
include that as you now it's really just
like a like a dashboard part and yeah
CO2 data is always also interesting but
I would like to um use the time more to
get onto the second
part okay yeah a little tiny break also
some some little art from XKCD another
art I I like this especially so what's
this is self- referencing
plot and yeah and I'm really curious
whether this is kind of true yeah so the
the middle plot shows the amount of
black by panel so here is that many
black here is that many black and here
is that many black and um yeah that
would be really cool to check whether
this actually works
f um okay second part the deployment so
having this um reactive notebook the
idea is that's let's make it totally
simple yeah to have the base as this
reactive notebook that we can build
products in no time
and yeah and one
part wait wait sorry I was moving back
and forth oh yeah first
slide so there are couple of whoops
sorry I yeah there are a couple of
features now in the in the cloud easiest
would be I now show you the cloud but
because life demos haven't been allowed
we now need to to work kind of with the
feature set so if you if you out there
you see just an overview of your GitHub
repositories this is how how it's
structured you can open new repositories
you can import existing repositories and
I have now P data
an example here yeah and you have little
little H what is this
um lenses over here which then are
different kinds of environments and you
can create new ones so the idea is we
have a pro environment which always
shows kind of the this yeah the result
with which is not being able to change
but the sliders yeah you have this
Interac activity which is intended but
you don't have the possibility to
develop it so a viewer perspective so to
say yeah and then we have couple of
death environments I've been working a
lot and it's always really awesome to
have kind of the possibility to create a
separate development environment where
you can just change what you want um and
they are put together um with Git
Version Control so prod is always
listening on on the main branch and
grabbing what what was changed and these
are on different branches they always
have their the separate uh independent
Branch so that you really can work
smoothly together and yeah and you can
create whatever other brand you like for
a feature request but you can also work
together on on one part so it's possible
that if one works on the notebook some
opens the same URL they just work
together on the notebook and see each
other's changes so this collaborative
feature is also
there and so this is one part of the
integration in a company setting um this
slide yeah it just shows that there's um
an easy entry if you start working with
this you also get a couple of example
notebooks so what you see here is that
the support
all three standard languages I would say
for doing data science Julia Python and
R and Julia is there for while actually
Julia's so this reactive notebook is
built in Julia first supported and what
I added now the last month is Pyon and R
so this is what you've already seen kind
of on the python side it's really a
super new thing yeah previously only
Julia was supported and now the other
language as
well and yeah welome dashboard reps and
streams are the three examples which are
there so that people can easily get
started and the last important video I
think and we may go through it a bit um
slower let's see um is this one so the
key parts now that we have the
development and the production which are
there to change it and then for the
final View and we can use the very same
notebook to also bridge the gap so
usually in in these yeah development
settings you have automated tests as the
bridge if you change something yeah
before making it live yeah to make it
into the product you usually want to run
automated test in some way and the cool
thing is now because this notebook is
stored as a python file we can just run
the python file as a simple test and and
in the in the notbook we can also kind
of do extra checks like if we are in the
test environment we can check this or
this extra and this makes kind of for
really smooth Complete product life
cycle yeah we use the very same notebook
for all stages we develop it by changing
the part yeah we test it by just running
it one one time through yeah and then we
have the product at the end which is
just the same notebook but without the
possibility to to change the code part
and this is super intuitive and let's
take a look into it so I hope this video
is also playing yeah so I'm at the front
end I'm going into the death environment
environment and now I'm I seeing a
couple of
example um notebooks which are different
because it's a bit older recording of
mine and I changed a couple of things in
my python notebook and now I have a
little interface which says update
production I can put a title in the
description it will update and give me a
link to GitHub this will have created
automatically uh a pull
request and this pull request it was
really fast
okay so we we look into it again
um
um it lags a little
bit be patient with
me yeah okay so we go to the def
environment um we see on the overview of
our notebooks we've changed something to
the python notebook we enter at
description of our
changes and then requests an update
which translates this into a GitHub pull
request and we can jump there and now
using kind of just standard GitHub we we
can discuss we can look into the file
changes which is just really just a
plain python file
and
um wait a
second
okay so this is a bit more difficult
than hoped for it doesn't jump back when
I want to jump
back usually should
hold okay I'm going over it a third time
but it seems like
the yeah
so okay and the the key part is now that
we have an automated testing which is
really totally automated so someone who
is using this notebook doesn't need to
Tinker with it it's um it grabs all the
files and just runs them automatically
and the key thing I want to highlight is
um this part over here some checks
haven't completed yet so it completes
one line for each notebook and tests
it
I think we we should leave it with that
um this I I was not aware that I pressed
next now and we are on the next
slide um yeah okay so this is the key
part having kind of development test and
production all in one and you can use it
without real knowledge of git yeah you
see it this git pole request is the
thing where we can kind of integrate
with existing Version Control best
practice that's there but you don't need
to understand good for it yeah so you
just use it you make comments there and
tell please change this you go back to
the notebook and change it and you do
another update request and and the pull
request will update itself and if you
have actually complex merge situations
which appear in Version Control someone
changed this another one changed this
then this is also handled for you
there's an automatic um yeah resolution
process which will then just have the
conflicting files next to each other you
can look into both yeah and you decide
what you want to to keep the other one
you delete and this whole process
doesn't need in-depth git knowledge
actually you don't need to execute a
single git command but you still have
this integrated Version
Control so so this is really also
simplified and and all this is kind of
powered by this reactive notebook being
so simple and that it can be the same
yeah at the same time the experiment
the experiment environment as well as
then um the final
product okay so behind the scene a
couple of Technologies I used um main
technology here is kubernetes actually
because it need to run somewhere and
this is also what I Envision for the
future
plan namely um I also want this to
support big data on the Julia side
there's couple there's currently uh yeah
one thing which is
missing um I hope for that it's going to
be there in the next year so that Julia
big data in a sense can be activated
from The Notebook from the python side I
think it's even simpler it's just that
the Pyon support wasn't there since yeah
a couple of weeks and and that would
also be nice to have the p p Spar
cluster just readily available Al or Ray
cluster and the thing this would work is
just that you start a cluster in the
notebook you say give me 10 machines
yeah and because it's a kubernetes
cluster it gives you 10 machines yeah
and then you can interact with these
machines and then finally you say if I
did everything thank you um then I
destroy my cluster again and I was
always missing this kind of approach
when I myself been doing big data like
the configuration of what resources I
want was always done outside my script
and I dislike this a little bit yeah
that you have this configuration extra
ra and you need to manage it extra and
then this approach here would be kind of
really you have your script and your
script does what your script does and
and it says give me five extra machines
to that I can do my computation and you
get five extra machines to to do your
computation and you can also make this
then of course much more dynamically
yeah so you can check the data yeah I
have so much data and hence I need so so
many machines yeah and I I missed this
and in current Big Data setting and I I
really hope that um the big data support
is there and it's set up on kubernetes
exactly to support also this use case
it's just yeah one one further step
which needs to be done and the notebook
itself is uh called actually Pluto in
the Julia world and yeah run also with
Julia I actually by now Al got a little
sticker a Pluto sticker um
yeah okay so I think um this is the
key here so of a little summary so you
can use this reactive notebook for
almost everything which you like in data
experiment dashboard transform events
building
pipelines and big data is plan of the
future and then you you can go to Cloud
Jolan
.io um which is as of now already hosted
reactive notebook service just log in
with GitHub and you can use it you can
collaborate with your team on the same
um notebook but you can also just create
um different environments which are
completely separate which is also really
nice and you have this def test prod
complete automation so that's super
simple to to create dashboards just by
by following this uh reactive notebook
style I usually give one month free exes
so please be welcome to try it out and
look whether it fits your uh your
needs okay and yeah this my my last
slide with a little LinkedIn QR code Cod
so you're welcome to follow me and yeah
thank
you hi St thanks a lot thanks a lot for
this presentation I have h i wondering
about uh your product H what is your
Niche audience I am trying to think uh
are you trying to Target a team of I
don't know data science that they want
to go work together but they don't need
to know G but probably many data
scientist know g h and I I'm trying to
figure out exactly who are can we sell
the product because I think that there
is a big potential as where you you are
showing here that there is a dep uh
option where the developers can actually
work and the broad option that you can
actually show to your client client
facing so my question is like what
exactly what needs are you
targeting as a company in your startup
thank you very much for the question
yeah so so the history is really like I
I got I saw this notebook yeah this
reactor notebook in the Julia world and
I thought this would be kind of a a
relatively easy pluck andplay solution
which which really gives a uh a benefit
so it's more like lwh hanging fruit
which motivated to go in this direction
and it's so much so important to find
kind of the customers who would really
benefit from this this is currently a
process which I'm in to to really
understand who is rather the target
Group which would be early enthusiasts
in this
realm in the long
run I I Envision that this is really
kind of something which can simplify a
lot of companies data sign setup so I've
been working in a couple of companies
where where you have engineers then
maybe some data scientist and then you
still have another group yeah of more
data and the lists which use bi tools
Tableau yeah to to create final
dashboards and I I always felt like this
is quite a complexity yeah so and and I
hope that the reactive notebook is able
to kind of unify this a bit more we have
another talk of DBT currently at the
other side going this is also a
motivator yeah where where people kind
of build systems which rather yeah bring
people together from these sides yeah
DBT does it via SQL
and and this does it why kind of being
script-like yeah and and be yeah writing
scripts is still something completely
simpler much simpler than programming in
a full sense
and it's kind of another Sweet Spot
between these parts yeah but but I I
really hope that it still can do the
same for Force yeah that to bring people
together from these different parts so
that you don't have the team boundaries
and resource boundaries between them
yeah until you get product out there but
you can really just bring out a product
within two days yeah and just because
it's so so unified and there really
every company comes into play it's just
that they won't be the first early
adopters and it's bit hard to to really
get it to to the Target Group which
could also be early adopters
yeah awesome question thank you very
much
much so one thing that you mentioned is
that you heavily um that all all of the
things that you do are heavily based on
Bluto and when I checked it out like one
year ago it didn't support Python and I
yet and you also mentioned that you
added that did you add that specifically
to cholin doio or do you now have you
own fork or have you contribute to that
upstream or how does this work oh that's
a perfect question yeah I was expecting
this even earlier today but yeah it
comes now so indeed it's currently on my
own Fork um there it's live and upstream
and can be tested but for the long run
it's definitely planned to get this part
in open source it's not planned to get
every part in into open source which is
there on cloud. ja.io so it's definitely
intended to be on to stay a custom Fork
but the python support and um especially
the python support the r support is
actually a bit more tricky but python
just works lovely yeah that's full
support kind of this would be great to
get out into um the the mainstream Pluto
Branch the mainstream Pluto repository
and it's just because of personal
resources it's more goal for the next
year so I won't focus on this within the
next month but I'll rather focus on on
getting to the right early adopter
Target group and and get traction on
really making this a sustainable
business yeah but it's definitely
planned to to have this Pyon support
there to yeah to circumvent this vendor
log in so that the core part is really
open and then people can be sure to to
use whatever they build outside of
cloud.
and. thank you for the
question thanks thanks a lot I think uh
yeah I think we are exactly we are on
thanks a lot and happy to reach out yeah
absolutely absolutely let's give him an
Applause and thanks a lot for for this
inspiring thank very
[Applause]
[Music]
much